la question à poser est que les noirs peuvent entrer les
noirs peuvent aller à la plage mais peuvent-
ils posséder un magasin sur la plage
Je ne suis pas Je ne suis pas un porte-parole blanc de
la communauté noire Je n'ai pas de mandat
Je ne suis pas un politicien Je suis  juste je suis un
observateur
[Musique]
quand j'avais 16 17
j'ai traversé une période de phase dans ma
vie où je voulais être noir très
désespérément
pas pour des raisons politiques pour des
raisons culturelles il y avait certaines choses que
je trouvais très belles et très
attrayant et plus tard
j'ai trouvé un moyen d'intégrer cela dans ma
vie et d'être un intermédiaire un
homme marginal un homme entre les deux
et c'est en fait beaucoup plus
intéressant
[Musique]
c'est une figure masculine forte
était mon beau-père
qui était journaliste
et  un amoureux de la musique africaine
mais la personne qui m'a vraiment donné un était
une sorte de héros pour moi ma première année j'étais
un
nettoyeur d'appartement zoulou qui vivait
au coin de la rue où je
vivais
c'était un guerrier danseur guitariste ainsi
que
son  mon nom était Charlie Mozilla
c'est lui qui m'a appris à
jouer de la guitare et à danser
[Musique]
elle avait raison elle de son côté
je rentrais de l'école et je
disparaissais
le mardi soir jeudi soir samedi
et dimanche je danserais
et à tout autre moment après l'école, si je voyais
des musiciens de rue, je disparaissais
donc je n'avais pas de vie de famille normale
en général parce que mon beau-père était
divorcé, ma mère vivait seule et
j'étais l'homme de la maison mais je n'étais
jamais là
[Musique]
la culture juive avait quelque chose à
voir avec je ne pense pas mais ma mère le
pense mais je ne pense pas
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'
Afrikaans en Afrique du Sud
des gens courageux qui se sont levés contre
l'apartheid qui parlent africain  langues
et qui ont rejoint la lutte pour
démanteler l'apartheid, donc je ne pense pas qu'il
y ait quoi que ce soit
euh
euh dans la psyché afrikaans
qui soit intrinsèquement brutale je pense juste
qu'on leur a refusé la bonne
expérience je m'est vu accorder le droit ou
une bonne expérience c'est vraiment ce que c'est
est
[Musique]
en Afrique du Sud de l'âge de sept ans
jusqu'à l'âge d'environ neuf ans et je suis allé dans
une école réservée aux Blancs quand je suis allé en
Zambie Je suis allé dans une école non raciale pendant
deux ans, ce qui a été un choc pour moi
et ça  a été la première
expérience de réalisation indirecte de
non-apartheid qui a évidemment
exagéré l'expérience de l'apartheid
et puis quand je suis retourné en
Afrique du Sud quand j'avais 11 ans,
ce fut un choc de retourner dans
une ville blanche juste une ville blanche où nous allons à
l'école  la culture
[musicale] étrangère
ou la culture esquimaude
peu importe c'est que j'ai trouvé un foyer
dans une certaine culture n'importe qui peut
trouver un foyer toutes les cultures sont humaines et
fondamentalement je vous savez je pense que j'aime j'aime
m'évader  des noirs et des
blancs que j'aime en Afrique du Sud,
je parle juste des cultures humaines
[Musique]
écrire un bon matériel et donc je lui ai dit puis-je puis-je
enregistrer ce que vous
jouez et il a dit qu'est-ce que tu veux dire
je  dit bien j'ai une machine
qui peut prendre ce que vous jouez et
l'attraper et il a dit non j'ai dit non plus ce n'est pas
facile vous n'aviez jamais vu de
magnétophone auparavant
alors j'ai apporté le magnétophone et il a
chanté et j'ai tapé  enregistré la chanson
l'a arrêté et je l'ai rejoué et il a
sauté et il a dit qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
un magnétophone et vous savez que vous pouvez en acheter
un voir où puis-je en acheter un j'ai dit
lui dire le magasin
alors Eric ils ont dit laisse moi faire  encore une fois
j'ai tapé enregistrer beaucoup de chansons parce qu'il
était vraiment excité par ça et puis
il m'a dit de venir chez lui la
semaine prochaine et quand je suis arrivé euh
il très fièrement il avait acheté un
magnétophone il avait enregistré une salle de  chansons
il m'a donné la cassette il a dit qu'il y avait
de nouvelles chansons
[Musique]
le mouvement démocrate de masse
euh l'a rencontrée et avec certains de ses
partisans et
[Musique] euh euh
essentiellement essayer de la discipliner et
de la ramener dans le mouvement
je  pense que tout attend
en attendant le procès parce qu'il n'y a pas
encore eu de procès
[Musique]
c'est incorrect parce que
nous avons maintenant des preuves archéologiques de l'
exploitation minière euh dans le transvaal qui remonte
à euh
700 après
JC et nous avons sur le dans  empangeni
nous avons maintenant une preuve archéologique claire
qu'il y avait des tribus qui
y vivaient euh il y a 1500 ans donc vous savez que c'est
incorrect
etc donc clairement le niveau de
production et le niveau de
vie du travail est supérieur à l'ensemble de
la zone sud-africaine
euh
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ce que je pense
si nous regardons la Côte d'Ivoire nous pourrions
avoir un problème je  pensez peut-être que si vous regardez le
Kenya, vous pourriez avoir un problème, je
ne sais pas, mais comme pour le reste de l'Afrique,
certainement
[Musique]
Je pense que le gouvernement salvateur est conscient
de l'euphorie actuelle dans les médias
à propos de l'Europe de l'Est
et des changements dramatiques qui  se
passent là-bas et il veut surfer sur
la vague de l'optimisme
les changements qui se sont produits et se
produiront se
produiront à un niveau social c'est-à-dire
les plages hôtels restaurants Etc qui
ne met en aucun cas en danger le pouvoir et
ne  t cela implique un
transfert de pouvoir transfert de pouvoir
nous avons toujours l'apartheid économique et nous
avons toujours l'apartheid politique la
question à poser est que les noirs peuvent entrer les
noirs peuvent aller à la plage mais peuvent-
ils posséder un magasin sur la plage
[Musique]
mes déclarations et mes  les perceptions sont
entièrement les miennes et je ne suis connecté à
personne, à aucune organisation, à aucun parti ou à
aucun groupe de personnes, c'est purement
[Music]
euh
un artiste et un activiste culturel qui
cherche et essaie de donner un sens
à ce qui se passe autour de lui
[Musique]
Je ne serai sur aucun signe
merci
euh
je pense que ça dépend de quel genre de
puissance tu parles parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de modèles différents qui
circulent euh le modèle dominant c'est
un homme un bateau dans le  Afrique du Sud unie
mais il y a un autre modèle d'
Afrique du Sud fédérée euh il y a beaucoup de
modèles différents qui circulent j'ai
personnellement soutenu le premier
Franchise universelle
je pense qu'il est clair que les blancs
auront toujours une position très très très puissante
et dominante dans  l'économie et
donc indirectement dans la politique ainsi
et l'ANC et d'autres
organisations noires sont conscientes que
le bannissement des droits du Mozambique
du Zimbabwe et d'autres pays
a été dévastateur pour ces pays et
ils sont très soucieux de garder leurs
blancs là-bas l'exécutif de l'ANC a  il y a
des blancs dessus tu sais que c'est donc si nous
parlons d'une
sorte d'Afrique du Sud non raciale
dialectique négative intime parce que